welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am
your one and only full-time permanent
host but for today's episode i am going
to be joined by a special temporary
guest co-host his name is greg knuckles
greg thanks for joining me
it is an honor and a privilege and i
thank you for having me on absolutely um
so i mentioned in last week's episode we
are changing up the format a little bit
we're doing episodes every single week
so they're going to be twice as frequent
but about half as long
and last week we ran out of time to do
some of our q and a's so we decided that
for the first time in a while we're
going to do a total q a episode today so
it's all going to be question and answer
so we will dive right into that but
before we do that
a couple things if you enjoy the show
and you want to support it there are
several ways that you can do that you
can like rate and subscribe the show and
share it with others you could use our
discount code at bulksupplements.com the
code is sbs pod that gets you a five
percent discount at bulksupplements.com
you could also subscribe to the mass
research review that greg and i are both
co-authors of
and finally if you want to check out our
diet app called macro factor we do have
a free trial so you can take it for a
spin see if you like it and that would
be a great way to support the show and
we would certainly appreciate that so
now we're going to get into some
questions and answers i am going to
start we're going to go back and forth
here but first i got a question from
dylan and dylan asked
i've got a question about protein
metabolism was looking at a paper
protein over feeding resulted in no
gains in body fat even though the
average caloric increase was around 800
calories so dylan was wondering
if if there's even a possible mechanism
that that our body can use to convert
amino acids into
free fatty acids and then store them
ultimately as fat tissue
so basically the question was you know
the the root of it there are a couple
papers uh
looking at very high protein overfeeding
and in those papers there's a curious
lack of fat storage so
basically they said hey you know have
these really high protein intakes we're
talking upwards of three or four grams
per kilogram per day so you know the rda
for protein in america that the
guideline says to shoot for like 0.8
grams of protein per kilogram of body
mass per day we're talking about in
these over feeding studies three and a
half sometimes even close to four and a
half grams per kilogram which is a ton
of protein but in the course of these
studies these individuals who were free
living individuals uh were instructed
hey eat these really high protein
intakes but keep doing your thing uh
lift some weights we'll see what happens
and so over the course of eight weeks
you know in one of these studies there
was really a series of three of these
over feeding studies by antonio and
colleagues
in one of them for example like the uh
the poster mentioned here
theoretically the high protein group was
eating like 800 extra calories compared
to the control group
and over an eight-week span of time they
did not seem to accumulate any
additional fat mass compared to the
other group eating 800 fewer calories
and that is a really astronomical
calorie gap between group
between groups so before i get into
some of the applied research on the
topic the first part of the question was
is it even possible for us to really do
anything with these extra calories that
are coming from protein over feeding can
we use them for energy can we store them
for fat and the very simple answer is
yes
so um our body is pretty good at stuff
which is
one of the reasons that there's so much
argument in the nutrition world is
because like you can go on a really wide
range of diets and feel pretty okay and
if you're really excited about your diet
you might even feel great about it you
know so that's why you see so many
people saying
i went virtually no carb or i went
really low fat or all animal product or
all plant product and everybody's stoked
about it and everybody feels good yeah
there are about a half dozen different
redundant pathways to accomplish
virtually anything that you'd want to do
with very few exceptions like you know
essential amino acids there are a
handful that your body can't manufacture
itself most other things you'd want to
do related to energy metabolism there
are a lot of roads that that lead to
rome exactly so when our bodies breaking
down carbs a lot of times what we're
trying to basically get to the kind of
end destination is let's turn this into
some pyruvate or some acetyl coa and
let's plug those into the pathways of
energy metabolism we can throw those you
know we can do glycolysis with carbs
obviously we can also you know throw
that acetyl coa into the krebs cycle uh
use some of the products from there
throw them into the electron transport
chain
we're using these kind of basic
foundational building blocks that
contain energy throwing them through
these pathways and getting atp as a
result and whatever's left over we can
find a way to kind of make sure that
we're storing fat when we have excess
energy and you know we can do so much
inner conversion because when we're
breaking down carbs when we're breaking
down fats when we're breaking down
protein after we kind of strip the amino
group off of extra extra protein in the
diet you know we take that amino group
off and then we're left with what's left
and we can still turn that into pyruvate
turn that into acetyl coa or it'll turn
into an intermediate that can go right
into the krebs cycle or the tca cycle so
when we're talking about metabolism of
carbs and fats and protein
it's kind of like dealing with currency
like we can exchange it when we need to
exchange it you're not going to
end up with you know a huge amount of
currency and say ah it's the wrong
currency there's just nothing i can do
here there are exchanges that are
possible and we're ultimately breaking
it down into the same energy containing
building blocks that we're throwing into
pathways whether those pathways are
going toward
creating atp or we're just funneling
that towards storage for later use
so macro macronutrient metabolism is
extremely flexible
if we have a bunch of extra calories
coming in from fat we can deal with that
energy and the way we deal with it is we
either oxidize it for atp in the short
term or we convert it to something that
we can store for later and in some cases
that will be fat now a lot of times
people will look at these types of
questions and they will kind of skip a
step and go straight to pubmed
like i think there's a lot of value
we've talked about this before if you
want to get a good handle on general
metabolism you want to start at the
textbook rather than going straight to
the individual experimental evidence
right so sometimes i'll see people who
are like looking for experimental
evidence of protein getting directly
converted to fat for storage you want to
take several steps back get the lay of
the land for metabolism and then start
looking for what actually happens in
experimental conditions so a great
example that's analogous is a lot of
times people will
wonder if we can store extra carbs as
fat you know if you have a really high
carb diet and you're over feeding and
it's the same kind of question do we
have pathways where we can convert
carbohydrate into fat um and then store
that sure we do but the body would much
rather just burn off the extra carbs to
the extent that it can and just store
the dietary fat that's already fat so a
lot of times we'll see these really high
carb overfeeding studies
and experimentally it looks like there's
not a lot of conversion to fat
you know just straight conversion carb
to fat it doesn't mean it's not possible
doesn't mean we don't have the pathways
it's just the body is crunching the
numbers and saying i'd much rather just
oxidize the carbs and store the fat and
if i really must then sure i'll do some
conversion of carbs to fat so it's a
kind of a similar deal with protein um
so yeah protein if we want to store it
as fat if we have to we can ultimately
convert it all the way down to like
acetyl coa and then do lipogenesis with
that acetyl coa and we can store it away
so that's the the short answer is yeah
if you're over feeding whether you're
over feeding carb fat protein whatever
there are going to be differences in the
pathways getting utilized in terms of
you know what our body prefers to do in
certain situations
the efficiency of fat storage will be
different so if you over feed with 800
calories worth of carbs versus fat
versus protein you're probably going to
have you know
just due to the thermic effect of
feeding the fat is going to get stored
very very easily
the thermic effect of carbohydrate is a
little bit higher we might not store it
with the exact same efficiency uh and
then protein has the highest thermic
effect so if you're going to say i'm
going to over feed no matter what with a
thousand extra extra calories on top of
what i'm already eating
what can i over feed and have the
smallest relative amount of fat gain it
probably would go in that order right so
you you'd have an easier time storing
the most
most fat tissue coming from fat as a in
an overfeeding scenario slightly less
with carbs but it's kind of negligible
and then slightly less again with
protein due to due to the thermic effect
now
one thing that i think is important to
recognize when it comes to the specific
studies being mentioned here by antonio
and colleagues
this is no fault of the participants or
the researchers i want to say that on
the front end here
but
i am very skeptical
about the idea that there's these 800
extra calories and we simply don't know
where they're going i'm also skeptical
that it's just 800 calories of like
straight thermogenesis like that doesn't
line up well with our understanding of
metabolism and energetics i think what
you have to keep in mind with the
studies by antonio
is these are free living participants
and self-reported
dietary data
so i think a really informative paper is
one by han and colleagues cody han is
actually one of our coaches at stronger
by science but they did a study where
they had three different overfeeding
conditions
and in one of them it was they were
trying to get people to just ramp up
their whey protein week over week over
week so they said like week one here
take some protein but week two and week
three and week four all the way to week
six they were supposed to increase their
protein intake by 25 grams every single
week
and what happened in that study over six
weeks and they did very very thorough
nutrition reporting
it just didn't happen
like the people started on high protein
diets and if you've ever tried to go
from like a very high protein diet to a
very very high protein diet
it's not fun no and like you would only
do it if you literally had to yeah so
like i mean they basically started
around like 175 grams a day of protein
and they were supposed to increase 25
grams every week for six weeks they
ended up getting to like 195 or 200 and
being like whatever dude i'm done and
actually their their total calorie
intake was lower than the other two
groups because
you know trying to force feed yourself
whey protein it sucks and it's also very
satiating so what you'll find is if
you're trying to give yourself
300 grams of weight of protein a day
mostly coming from whey you're probably
gonna find that you're not eating much
else because you're very very full
and unless someone's making you do it
you're probably gonna do that for like
three days and be like this sucks i'm
not gonna do this anymore so i've got a
story related to that i don't know if
i've talked about this on the podcast
before i i feel like i have but i'm not
positive but uh back in the day
um
when i was like maybe 19 or 20 or so i
learned about dc like style bodybuilding
like dog crap training
and uh
you know so i got into all of that and
there's nutrition recommendations that
go along with it i don't remember all of
them but one of the kind of bedrocks
like one of the cornerstones of
nutrition advice in that community is
just like ah you know regardless of the
details just eat like four or five
hundred grams of protein per day and
everything else will more or less sort
itself out um so i was like okay cool
like i'll give that a shot uh so i tried
like i was tracking everything and i was
averaging something north of 400 grams
of protein for like
two weeks and i just said [ __ ] that like
i i can't do this i i can maybe shoot
for 300 grams per day uh and like i was
in college as well like i had a meal
plan um
but like the cafeteria didn't have many
like good relatively low calorie high
protein options so what my diet looked
like at the time is they had this little
salad bar where you could put like
little cubes of ham on top of your salad
and like deli ham is is pretty lean uh
so i would just like go and get a plate
and just load it up with like little
like tiny cubed ham slices and just eat
that with a
little like ham cubes and just eat that
with a spoon um
which i imagine is probably more
satiating than whey protein and also ham
is very salty so i think i was gonna say
i hope that your blood pressure isn't
too responsive to dietary sodium no i i
don't think it is i don't think i'm like
a sodium blood pressure responder uh but
over just like the first week of doing
that i put on like eight pounds which i
think i think was 100 water retention
from how much deli ham i was eating um
but yeah that [ __ ] was [ __ ] miserable
dude yeah um
so anyone who is actually following that
dietary advice
i don't think you benefit from eating
that much protein but
if you are doing that and doing it
consistently uh you have a lot more
willpower to eat protein than i do
yeah yeah so
like i said there's a study by han and
colleagues which gives a window into
like what is the likelihood that a lot
of people really are
just going like four and a half grams
per kilogram per day and not having a
huge
like
kind of like non-volitional reduction in
calorie intake uh or or at least just a
total replacement of their calories that
they were that would have been carbs and
fat just replacing that with protein i
mean when you look at really
meticulously reported studies like the
one by han and colleagues you'll see
it's not very typical for people to be
able to say oh yeah i'll just like
triple my protein intake or double it
and i'll just leave everything else the
same like it's not easy to do yeah um
and there's also a study by bray and
colleagues in 2012
where they did very rigorous
overfeeding with
varying levels of protein so like the
levels of protein were five percent of
energy up to 25 percent of energy which
i think spanned all the way from like
right around the rda like close to that
like point seven or point eight grams
per kilogram uh all the way up to like
three grams per kilogram and this study
was complete inpatient metabolic ward
every calorie that these individuals
consumed for the study period um and i
think it was eight weeks which is really
impressive if that's the case
every morsel they ate was prepared and
provided by the research staff and every
instance of them consuming calories was
supervised by the research staff
and in that scenario there was nothing
weird about protein overfeeding there
was no like loophole where it's like man
these are like free calories
everything made sense in terms of the
amount of fat mass that was gained and
the amount of fat free mass that was
gained so
with protein over feeding
the closer you get to really tightly
controlled designs the more protein
overfeeding completely makes sense and
does exactly what you'd expect
the additional calories there's a little
bit of
increase in energy expenditure due to
the thermic effect of feeding that might
have a little impact on the propensity
to store fat just because of burning
calories nothing
biochemically weird about that
uh and then the fat free mass you know
it really just comes down to
you know if you're having a huge
increase in protein intake from a very
low protein diet you're probably going
to store some extra fat free mass just
because you were under eating protein
previously but uh yeah i know that there
are some studies floating around that
make it seem like there's some weird
biochemical stuff going on with protein
overfeeding almost like it's some kind
of biochemistry loophole that gives you
free calories it's really not the case
and uh unfortunately you know the
calories that are going in are going to
be dealt with either through an increase
in thermogenesis or
just storage of tissue so
uh that's it yeah so high protein
overfeeding can it lead to fat gain
absolutely and that fat gain is
very much in line with what we would
calculate based on our understanding of
metabolism
all right you are up greg alrighty so uh
this first question i'm addressing is
from derek in the facebook group uh and
i'm primarily addressing it not because
i have a great answer to it but because
every time we throw up q and a threads
uh someone asks some variation of this
question uh and i've avoided attempting
to answer it for a long time so whatever
just gonna rip the band-aid off uh
mostly just to be able to link this
every other time this question comes up
anyway the question is uh i have always
wondered why i ache more during my
deload week it doesn't even need to be
after an entire block of training my
back tends to ache more a few days into
the deload than it ever does during my
training weeks i have more nagging
aching and pains as well so you know
basically why might someone
be experiencing more physical discomfort
during deload weeks than you know when
they're actually like actively training
pretty hard
so the
explanation that i've heard for this so
we want one thing just to note on the
front end uh i've not seen
like direct human research on this so
we're we're purely in the realm of
anecdote and kind of looking around for
potential explanatory mechanisms so
anyone
who is answering this question with a
super high degree of confidence uh
either they're aware of research that i
wasn't
able to find or they're just kind of
bullshitting so just
be aware of that on the front end uh and
i am going to do my best to not [ __ ]
you with this answer um but yeah so the
the explanation that i've heard from
other sources before
is that when you're training hard you're
putting stressors on your body
and as a result your sympathetic nervous
system output ramps up and along with
that comes increases in ketocholamine
levels so epinephrine norepinephrine uh
basically adrenaline
and those chemicals
can to some degree
uh like numb
pain or discomfort responses like you
know i'm sure you've heard anecdotes
from like athletes who maybe have a
rolled ankle but you know they put on an
ankle brace and get on the court and you
know they they just forget that they've
injured their ankle while they're
actually playing and then they get off
the court and like they're limping all
over the place like the the pain comes
back uh and so you know maybe maybe
that's just purely due to adrenaline
and
i don't know
that i fully buy that explanation for a
couple reasons
one is that
it is true that when you're putting a
lot of stressors on your body
even when you're not
necessarily
um you know
actively exercising your base like your
your catecholamine levels at rest could
still be elevated to some degree so if
you if you track hrv for example heart
rate variability that's one of those
things that it's roughly trying to
assess if you have
uh low heart rate variability even at
rest that means your
sympathetic nervous system even at rest
is ramped up a little bit
so um you know that dynamic is in play
but i i think that the
level of sympathetic nervous system
output and the level of adrenaline you
need to like
pretty significantly numb pain is quite
a bit higher than it would be
at rest even if it is somewhat elevated
from baseline you know so when you're
actually training you might get a pretty
intense analgesic response uh like a
pain reducing response from some of
those chemicals but even if they are
slightly elevated at rest i don't know
that it would be enough to be
physiologically relevant for like
numbing pain and discomfort and another
reason that i'm somewhat skeptical of
that explanation
is there are
other things that you can do that can
ramp up catecholamine output that also
have a tendency
to simultaneously increase pain
perception so for example after just
like one or two like very poor or very
short nights of sleep uh sympathetic
nervous system activity will ramp up
while you're awake basically just to try
to keep you awake and alert
even though you're you're poorly rested
um an inadequate sleep also tends to be
associated with increased pain
perception so there are other things
that have a similar effect on the
sympathetic nervous system as a training
block would that would tend to increase
pain perception rather than decrease it
so you know that that is uh
a set of physiological mechanisms that
may be related to this phenomenon to
some degree but i i'm skeptical that it
that it fully explains it
um
one other possibility is just that you
know maybe you ache more because you're
moving less overall so in in kind of
like
the pain and physical rehab literature
one of the things that you see pretty
consistently is that uh just exercise in
general has a
pretty
robust and consistent general analgesic
effect or in other words like if you
move more you tend to hurt less um
just you know not
not in all conceivable situations and
all conceivable things that might be
causing pain
but in general
if you're
if you're very sedentary
or if your activity levels decrease
quite a bit that could make you hurt a
little bit more and if you're a little
bit more active you tend to just be in a
little bit less discomfort um so you
know that could be all that's going on
like it's your deload week so you're
you're taking it easier in the gym and
maybe as a result like or even
purposefully one of the things people
will often do when they're deloading is
they just try to take it easy in general
like the idea being you know i'm trying
to rest i'm trying to recuperate so i'm
not going to go out of my way to be
active or i might even go out of my way
to be
a bit of a couch potato this week to
really
you know let myself fully recuperate
from this training block i just did so
you know that that could just be the
dynamic at play like your overall
activity levels are lower um you know
and as a result the general levels of
discomfort you feel are a bit higher so
that's another potential explanation
again i don't
i i don't think that would be a complete
explanation of this phenomenon but that
could be another uh input in play
um
and then another
potential explanation
um is it could just be a matter of of
your brain basically filtering the
inputs coming to it
and
kind of giving primacy to whatever the
most intense
input is so
that was that was a very bad just
introduction to this explanation but
basically like you're training hard
maybe you're experiencing some pretty
intense or you know at least like
moderate doms delayed onset muscle
soreness so you know it could be that
those
sensations like maybe a little back pain
maybe some joint aches or whatever um
like maybe those things
are there all the time but
there there's kind of a finite amount of
stuff that your brain can make you aware
of like your your conscious mind is is
limited in terms of like how much you
can perceive and process all at once and
so it could just be a matter of like you
know your your brain is trying to send
you what it perceives to be the most
relevant information and so you know it
makes you
aware of pain and discomfort and so it
could just be that you're you're
experiencing enough muscle soreness when
you're training hard that those kind of
like
lower level discomfort signals that are
getting to your brain
uh aren't intense enough to kind of get
pushed into your conscious
perception uh and then once you remove
some of those other
like
just
uncomfortable sensations uh as a result
of training then maybe some more of that
low level stuff uh is now
you know the most intense discomfort
you're feeling and so your brain just
kind of pushes that into your conscious
awareness so that that could be what's
going on as well
all of which is to say i think of those
three things i mentioned all of them
could be contributing none of them could
be contributing it's hard to say we
don't know for sure um so just generally
interpret that as food for thought
good stuff
i will admit um
i normally you're the person that takes
forever i went really long with my first
question so i'm gonna try to do this one
really quickly in our interest of our
dedication to
shorter episodes
uh where are we at already uh we're at
about we're close to 30 minutes oh yeah
so it's
not not great
[Laughter]
so uh i had a question from
numerous safety 3796 and this was from a
long time ago i also was kind of putting
this off much like you were with the
last question i i just didn't want to
get into it because it's about
ashwagandha
and performance effects so the question
is basically what are my thoughts about
ashwagandha for physical performance and
it also specifically refers to
a meta-analysis now when i first got
this question i was like cool a
meta-analysis i love digging into those
uh if you're a math subscriber like i
had a really
painful hobby for a while there of kind
of taking metas apart
finding some little calculation errors
and then putting them back together
um i say it was a painful hobby because
that takes so long if there's more than
like four studies
um so anyway i opened this up thinking
it'd be an opportunity because i know
the ashwagandha exercise literature is
not that big so i was like oh i can dig
into this and probably find some errors
and put it back together i think the
meta-analysis itself was done quite well
my concern is i just think the body of
literature is so
scattered and inconsistent
and i think the mechanisms are so vague
i truly don't know what to do with it
and usually when i'm there with a
supplement i say listen if you're really
intrigued and you want to give it a shot
there's enough safety data to suggest
that as long as it's not an adult rated
product and not just and you're
following dosing guidelines like
if you want to take a crack at it take a
crack at it but i haven't seen enough
evidence uh despite the existence of
this meta-analysis to
really feel good about recommending
ashwagandha for performance purposes
um if you look around at some of the
uh research that people often point at
when it comes to ashwagandha as a
performance booster there was one paper
that i see floating around every now and
then that you know
like
over the course of i think maybe eight
weeks or so uh you know it was kind of a
standard length for uh for a training
intervention it was like eight maybe ten
weeks or so
uh the ashwagandha group added 46
kilograms to their bench press
and so like yeah i don't know yeah it
was eight weeks so
maybe that happened maybe it didn't
but if it did happen
like a lot of kilos
my question is to whom does that really
generalize you know like yeah
ashwagandha is not going to add 46
kilograms to your bench press so i don't
know what to do with that particular
finding but that that's one that a lot
of people get
uh excited about and to be fair like
maybe they were just really really
really really untrained there was no
familiarization and so it was just like
hey over the next eight weeks we are
going to teach you how to bench press
and sprinkle in some additional
supplement magic and and here we go but
in any case there's nothing that i can
do with with that right yeah so
there's also um
yeah if you look at the effect sizes
within this meta analysis
um
you would kind of be left to conclude
that ashwagandha is
more effective than creatine
by a pretty comfortable margin and i
find that to be implausible uh at this
point in time just because of
inconsistency from study to study and
and also like i mentioned uh the the
mechanism doesn't make a lot of sense to
me
um
some papers will will talk very vaguely
about ashwagandha's mechanisms and say
like well it's
you know you're doing these stressful
things and ashwagandha will make them
less stressful and all of a sudden
intervention 46 more kilograms and i'm
like i got you got to get me closer to
how i got those 46 kilograms yeah i mean
if that is the relevant mechanism just
like dude you should see a similar
ergogenic effect from smoking weed right
but just doing a little something to
take the edge off in the evening but
yeah i mean i was looking at one paper
and it says it referred to this is a
quote anti-stress effects
neuroprotective effects immunomodulatory
effects and rejuvenating effects via the
herbs interplay with the nervous system
the endocrine system the cardiopulmonary
system energy production system and the
immune system including analgesic
antimicrobial anti-inflammatory
anti-tumor anti-stress anti-diabetic
neuroprotective immunoprotective and
cardioprotective effects good [ __ ] so
like
what am i supposed to do with that like
yeah it just does all things in all
context so
but when you when you start to dig into
it a little bit uh you basically will
find um
two primary like specific mechanisms one
is
cortisol reduction which i don't think
you could really say you know yeah
cortisol is leading to the effects we
see in that meta-analysis effects of
that magnitude man in in in addition to
that there was a
there was a paper i think it came from
stu phillips's lab
maybe like 2013 2014 thereabouts um like
like back when the acute hormone
hypothesis for for training adaptations
was was kind of the hot topic and people
are doing research to see like you know
does does that seem to be like the
primary mechanism for muscular
adaptations
so they they had a paper where they were
looking at the correlations between um
between hormonal responses to training
and uh resistance training adaptations
it was either strength gains or
hypertrophy it was one of the two um
but if memory serves because i didn't
pull this this paper up before recording
if memory serves they looked at changes
in testosterone
cortisol
growth hormone igf-1 i think it was
those four
and none of them were associated with
training adaptations except for cortisol
which was positively associated with
training adaptations right so like you
know i i wouldn't necessarily want to
take um
correlation data from a single paper at
face value but
i mean of the human data that i'm aware
of uh
a relatively large cortisol response
post training
probably either doesn't meaningfully
predict training adaptations or might be
positively predictive of training
adaptations so like if that's the main
mechanism you're hanging your hat on
like oh yeah this this reduces cortisol
i don't know i don't even know that
that's a good thing
right and you know there is a
distinction between you know kind of
basal resting cortisol throughout the
day versus the acute fluctuations from
training but yeah for sure again it's
yeah there's
minimal evidence to suggest that a
little reduction in cortisol whether
we're talking about during exercise post
exercise or throughout the day is going
to have dramatic effects on body
composition performance uh so and then
sometimes people say well no it's it's
affecting the hpa or the hpg axis but
it's more affecting testosterone it's
increasing testosterone and ashwagandha
is not increasing your testosterone
enough to have those types of ergogenic
effects you need a big change in
testosterone to have a significant
ergogenic effect on that magnitude has
anyone checked to see the ectisterone
content of uh
of ashwagandha that's a good question
um another mechanism that does come up
is sometimes they say listen it's got
antioxidant properties and that's good
but i wrote an article for stronger by
science about antioxidants there are
many of them they
do antioxidant things quite well and
they do not have these types of
performance outcomes so maybe to be fair
maybe ashwagandha is remarkably
efficacious as an ergogenic aid and we
simply have no idea what the mechanism
is
um but to me that's that's not enough to
get me really to latch onto a supplement
and recommend it i need to see
you know consistent plausible effect
sizes that make sense based on a
mechanism that has been supported by
some experimental research
and right now there's just really a
disconnect where the effect sizes are
really big there are very few of them
they are a bit inconsistent from study
to study
i can't really point to a mechanism that
would tie it all together so when it
comes to ashwagandha for performance i'm
personally going to sit this out
i've taken ashwagandha before for an
extended period of time because
there is some amount of evidence
suggesting that it might help with
attenuating symptoms of like very mild
anxiety um so i've taken it for that
whether or not i experienced a placebo
effect from it i don't really know
it didn't like change my life but it
seemed fine
but i certainly didn't notice pronounced
ergogenic effects when i was taking
ashwagandha for for that type of outcome
so um
you know if you're super intrigued by it
by all means you know you can give it a
shot just make sure you're not getting
an adult-rated product make sure you're
taking it within
recommended dosage guidelines you can
take a shot on it if you'd like but
personally i don't see strong evidence
supporting
a an ergogenic effect with plausible
consistent effect sizes with a mechanism
that would explain how it would be doing
that type of thing but i do want to say
i want to acknowledge that um you know
this does kind of fall under that
ayurvedic medicine umbrella there are
some
traditions and cultures in which
ashwagandha is held in really high
regard and so i don't mean to be
disrespectful to any of those
traditional elements or cultural
elements
if you really like using ashwagandha for
reasons uh that are based on you know
culture tradition whatever the case may
be i'm not trying to be a dick and you
know insult that or take away from that
or anything but when people have these
questions for us about supplements it's
usually through the prism of kind of
by the book evidence-based medicine or
evidence-based practice do you see
enough evidence
empirically to support this i'm not
seeing the experimental evidence
that i would need to justify promoting
it as an ergogenic aid yeah and i i just
want to add one thing to head off a
maybe like a potential criticism of the
the answer you just gave um so you know
one of the things you said is like
you'll
you might would have more faith in it if
there was more high quality human
research on it one one thing that i
know that
that some people's brains will go to
it's like well
well man like there's a reason that
there's not that much research on it
like it's an herb you can't patent it uh
there's no there's no profit motive so
like people people aren't going to
you know pour the same sort of money
into research because there's no way
that you can like monetize this the same
way you could other things like that
that's a common like anti-pharma talking
point um but in the case of supplement
research like
that that just doesn't pass the smell
test for reality because like a lot of
the most studied supplements out there
is [ __ ] that can't be patented because
it's naturally occurring so like
creatine for example or caffeine
or fish oil i think those are the three
like like one two and three the most
studied supplements in existence and
they're they're all stuff that uh
exists in nature that you can't patent
like you can you can package and sell it
but you know it's the same sort of thing
as an herbal extract um
so yeah i i know that some people
some people's brains will go there as
kind of an explanation for why there's
not more high quality human data on it
but
in the case of supplementation that
that critique just doesn't hold water
yeah and and like i said uh some of
these findings they're just
the effect sizes just seem too big to me
and i know that
uh you know when people hear that the
first thing they think is just like
straight up fraud that's not what i'm
suggesting but like
a lot of times with studies the first
few papers that trickle out for any
particular
supplement or treatment whatever the
case may be
a lot of times we see really inflated
effect sizes and we see effect sizes
that are not generalizable that are not
representative of the true effect size
and only after we get a ton of different
studies do we start to see oh the early
phase of research for this ingredient we
saw a lot of publication bias and we saw
a lot of inflated effect sizes that were
not necessarily due to fraud or anything
like that but they were just sampling
error and kind of the like first finders
effect where where the first time you do
it uh you you know there could be
several
very uninteresting ashwagandha studies
that are just kind of sitting in
cupboards you know in the file drawer
and uh you know it's only when you
happen to get this kind of
non-generalizable but flashy finding do
you say oh this is something that could
really make a splash so
anyway yeah i'm not that into it as an
ergogenic aid but if you're into it hey
more power to you
i feel you all right uh moving on i have
a question uh from the stronger by
science subreddit from no underscore
attention 69 69
uh who says greg how are your lifts with
weight loss have you been able to
maintain somewhat mitigating losses
any things you've found that have helped
maintain strength
that have helped you maintain your
strength while cutting
um
and so this is another question that
i've gotten a lot i i've been recently
doing like weekly instagram q and a's
and
this this question or some version of it
will be asked five or six times um
but since i don't save those q and a's
and we do save the podcast i'm gonna
answer it here um so yeah i've gotten a
lot weaker with my weight loss four
reasons that i think are partial well
that i know are largely unrelated to the
weight loss so um
i started my cut in february of last
year um towards the end of this month it
will be
a year that that the road to the stage
has been active
and i
am positive that i've gotten a lot
weaker uh through that process
uh but the primary reason why is through
a lot of that time i just wasn't lifting
um or wasn't lifting particularly hard
so last i don't remember for sure it was
either april or may it was like when it
was starting to get warm um anyway i
broke my wrist and uh [ __ ] up some of
the the ligaments in my left elbow
and so like a piece of advice that i
commonly give people and there's
research to support this is if you
injure one side of your body if you
continue training the other side of your
body it will help with strength
maintenance for the injured side that
you can't train um but yeah like i
didn't do that uh mostly because it was
my left arm which is yeah i'm a righty
my left arm is my weak one anyway if i
would have hurt my right arm i would
have said ah you know i'll keep training
my left arm that's fine um but yeah i
just
i don't have any need for my right arm
to get that much stronger
when my left is already injured and i
can't train it um
so yeah that contributed and then also
since
since it was like a wrist issue i had no
grip strength so you know i couldn't do
any like rowing or whatnot couldn't
really grip a bar well to deadlift um
also couldn't like just support
any weight on my shoulders to squat
didn't have the wrist mobility to front
squat um
like even a safety bar squat like just
just the the pressure from the handles
like i couldn't take any pressure down
on that wrist at all
so i just didn't do
much of anything for a few months while
that was rehabbing
and i think that was very very useful
for me actually so one of the
kind of like mental hurdles that i run
into when trying to lose weight is
since i do
value strength training so much and
since i value my own physical strength
so much
one of the
one of the kind of mental hurdles i'd
always run up against is like when a
diet would be going pretty well but my
strength would start taking a little bit
of a hit that made it
challenging to continue to be bought
into the diet um
just because like i i did kind of have
maybe like an irrational fear of getting
any weaker
so i think i think breaking my wrist and
not training for a while was actually
very useful because then i could just
kind of
metabolize that and take it in i'm like
well you know i can't train the way i
want to for a while i am going to get
weaker um but what's this other goal i
have i'm trying to lose weight okay cool
like i can i can just focus on that and
then like by the time everything was
healed up enough that i could start
training more consistently again i was
enough weaker that
uh it
instead of it being stressful like oh
man i'm i'm going to lose
strength from this like current high
level of strength it's like ah whatever
i'm already so much weaker that i can
just go lift weights and it's fun um and
i'm i'm not really losing anything on
the back end
um
so yeah like i
don't know the degree to which uh just
not training affected my strength versus
losing weight both of them probably
contributed uh but yeah i've gotten a
lot weaker and i'm at this point
completely fine with it um
and now now that i am training more
consistently again the strength is
coming back really quickly like uh the
first time like once my wrist could
handle compressive loading pretty well
and i i put some weight back on back on
the bar to bench press
uh
i ground out
a very very challenging single at 315
and then by like my third bench press
workout back um i did like a pretty
comfortable triple with 315 on low
incline so you know that's probably
somewhere around like a triple at 3
55ish for flat so you know it's coming
back quick and i'm sure a month from now
my strength will still be lower than it
was pre-cut but
like
i i'm pretty sure i'll retrain back to a
relatively strong place
anyway uh i don't know if that's the
answer you were looking for i've
definitely gotten weaker a lot of it was
just from not training um
and uh yeah just just accepting that i
was going to lose strength and
kind of using that injury as as a
mechanism to allow me to accept that i
think has actually been very very
helpful for me so
yep that's uh
that's where i'm at
good stuff
so i'm up next i got a question that's
been i've gotten like three questions
that are kind of like this so i kind of
merged them all into one
um
with the
road to athens taking the stronger by
science world by storm everybody's
crazy about it there's a lot of
questions about cardio these days so
someone asked me is high intensity
interval training better than
low or moderate intensity steady state
for uh for body composition purposes so
looking at different approaches to
cardio high intensity interval intervals
versus steady state exercise
and also what are some good interval
training protocols and how do you gauge
intensity for those protocols
so uh i had a very recent article in
mass that was about this there was a
meta-analysis by
james steele and colleagues and james is
very very good at doing research so
highly recommend his work um
they looked at a big old group of
studies comparing steady state versus
interval type training they were
specifically looking at changes in fat
mass and fat-free mass so looking at
body composition
and what they found was no meaningful
difference in terms of fat loss
or gains in fat free mass so fairly
modest effect for both outcomes uh in
both cases they lost
about a quarter of a kilogram of fat and
gained like a tenth of a kilogram a fat
free mass um which is an important point
so first of all
cardio or endurance type exercise uh
it's great for a lot of things um but
it's independent effects
on weight loss really are not that big
so
a lot of times some people say i'm going
to take up running as an independent
standalone fat loss
endeavor
and
in many cases you know you might find
that you have really really positive
impacts on your health really great
impacts on appetite regulation things
like that but you know as a standalone
fat loss
intervention
probably leaves a little bit to be
desired doesn't mean it's not great for
your health and well-being but if fat
loss and weight loss truly are the goal
you probably want to do a mixture of
doing some additional physical activity
whether it's cardio or otherwise and
then adding in a dietary component of
some type
anyway
it's important to recognize with this
meta-analysis
this was
only one of the studies in the
meta-analysis included resistance
training so that obviously is a
limitation considering that most of our
listeners uh do a lot of resistance
training um so the question is would the
analysis
would it have turned out way different
if if resistance training were
included in a lot of these individual
studies i would argue probably not um
you know the the interference effect is
usually where people start getting
really focused when you talk about
combining cardio with resistance
training
multiple meta-analyses now have shown
that the interference effect is pretty
minimal for strength
and
very minimal for hypertrophy as long as
your resistance training and your
endurance training component being
managed effectively like if you really
wanted to you could use the interference
effect to mess up your gains but you'd
have to be trying pretty hard you'd have
to be doing a lot of things poorly to
make that work in most cases or just
already be at a really really high level
in one of the two pursuits correct yeah
yeah but but in most cases uh adding a
little bit of cardio or endurance
training into uh your lifting program
very unlikely to have a catastrophic
effect on your strengths and and even
less likely when it comes to body
composition hypertrophy
uh now my favorite hit protocols that i
like to do if you choose to go that
route um you could take one approach
that would probably fall under the
umbrella of sprint interval training and
the distinction between high-intensity
interval training and sprint interval
training is pretty straightforward the
sprint stuff is all out it's maximal
intensity so i do a type of sprint
interval training every now and then
where i'll do 30 seconds
all out you know rpe 10 maximal
intensity and then i'll spend 90 seconds
below the kind i forget what the what
the term is but in
grad school they mentioned like the
conversation threshold basically an
intensity of endurance type exercise
where you could still hold a pretty
comfortable conversation while doing it
right so it's i don't know how to
convert that to a specific rpe but
pretty chill pretty light you're
basically using 90 seconds to recover
and then you're right back into another
30 second sprint so i'll do that for 10
or 15 sprints in whatever modality you
choose cycling running swimming whatever
the case may be
i also like a high intensity interval
training protocol that's very
straightforward it's just one minute on
one minute off
the
high intensity part of it i try to do it
an rpe of like nine or ten so like the
the way i would i would frame that is if
i'm doing it on a treadmill
by the end of that minute i'm like man
it's kind of
kind of drifting toward the back of the
treadmill a little bit you know it's
it's tough you you feel like you're
really at that nine or ten level with
the rpe out of 10 obviously and then
again the one minute recovery
i'll either rest entirely or i'll just
do some light stuff below that
conversational threshold where i could
easily hold a conversation while i'm
doing it another less intense protocol
i'll do is is quite similar but i'll do
two minutes on and two minutes off and
with that i knocked the rpe down a
little bit to like an eight to maybe
like a nine and a half so not knocking
the intensity down a little bit but
obviously doubling the duration of the
the high intensity interval there
and if i do that i might only do like
half the round so instead of doing 10
one minute high interval bouts i'll do
like five two minute high interval bouts
and like i said the the modality is not
critical uh cycling swimming rowing
running paddling whatever you want to do
you just want to make sure you find a
safe way to do it so you don't want to
throw yourself off the back of a
treadmill you don't want to be in a
precarious position where you like
fatigue yourself swimming in open water
obviously that would be dangerous if
you're not a strong swimmer but
yeah a lot of ways to do it and high
intensity interval training is you know
a very viable way to uh to get some of
the benefits of aerobic exercise or
cardio type or endurance type exercise
as long as you're not doing it so much
with such high intensity that you are
just
completely wiped out for your lifting
sessions you should be fine but that is
something to keep an eye on obviously
and then finally the biggest caveat is i
answered this question specifically
within the context of body composition
if you're adding some type of endurance
training
for reasons that go beyond body
composition or cardiovascular health or
thing cardio metabolic health things
like that if you're trying to add in
endurance type exercise to
cultivate a specific physiological
capacity if you're doing it for a
specific performance reason
it's a completely different answer
obviously when you're doing that
you need to make sure that you are
tailoring your endurance type exercise
to really target the key energy systems
that you're trying to develop
so that would be a completely different
scenario where you would have to really
sort out the details with your intensity
your duration your modality but if
you're just doing it for general health
and well-being or to burn a couple extra
calories
you know things of that nature really
not critical whether you pick one or the
other makes sense to me
all right um
where are we at time wise uh 54 minutes
all right so this will probably be my
last one i reckon
uh so colin quirk
from reddit asks um
have there been any attempts to quantify
the benefits associated with
personalizing training
for example working with a coach or
creating your own program versus
following a more general program
furthermore is there a training age
where this benefit kicks in true novices
probably don't need to personalize that
much uh at what point does this benefit
assuming it exists start to kick in
so yeah
basically just asking
is there
like have we quantified the benefits
associated with personalizing training
um
and in terms of
resistance training
not really um so there there was a
really really cool paper
uh published in frontiers a couple years
back uh the title of which is
effectiveness of an individualized
training based on force velocity
profiling during jumping by jimenez
reyes and colleagues
that will be linked in the show notes i
would recommend checking that out
what they did in that study essentially
is the athletes they they would bring
them in do a force velocity profile um
probably don't have time to explain how
how they would quantify whether someone
was strong versus fast but basically
there there is a theoretically optimal
uh force velocity profile for jumping
where
um you know if if you are naturally very
explosive like if your your angular
velocities can be very very fast com
like
with no load but you're relatively weak
uh if you kind of like pull that load
velocity profile up there somewhere in
the middle that would roughly correspond
with body weight uh that will
increase your your specific ability to
create force and power for jumping
versus someone who's already pretty
strong but then their their maximum
contractile velocity is quite slow if
you kind of if you're able to kind of
pull that curve out that would also
increase power output there towards the
middle of the curve where vertical
jumping is occurring so
basically they profiled all of all of
the subjects and
they had a group
where they
um
like trained whichever side of the curve
people were bad at so basically if
someone was strong but slow they would
just do like very very low weight over
speed type stuff to try to
improve maximum contractile velocity and
if someone was already
quite fast but relatively weak they
would just have them train maximal
strength to try to improve that
functional capacity
and then they had another group of
people as well who who kind of trained
all capacities just in general so they
would do um what's called like optimal
load training where essentially you
would train with the sorts of power and
force outputs that would be associated
with what you're trying to improve so in
this case vertical jump and then also
some strength work also some speed work
so just kind of like a generalized
vertical jumping program
and so in that study where they did
tailor the training intervention for all
of the individuals um the the group of
people on the individualized program did
have much better vertical jumping
outcomes than just kind of the more
generalized program did so you know i
kind of view that as a proof of concept
you know a maximum squat is not a
maximum vertical jump but it is kind of
a proof of concept that if you
um adequately quantify what people are
lacking in and develop
in individualized training intervention
to
you know target those things where
people could improve then you might have
have better outcomes but like i said
that's not that's not specifically like
trying to improve maximal strength um
one other thing just to generally note
is that oftentimes like this this
question asked about working with a
coach to create an individualized
program for you
one thing to note is that just merely
having a coach
regardless of the quality of their
programming might still improve your
results
so there have been a handful of studies
that have looked at supervised versus
unsupervised training or
supervised training with a high ratio of
lifters to trainers versus a low ratio
of lifters to trainers
and those studies will be linked in the
show notes as well but uh
what these studies find is essentially
they they will have two groups of people
they put them on the same training
program
and one of the groups has basically
research assistants
working with them the whole time so you
know loading the bar for them spotting
them giving them encouragement whatever
and then the other group of people there
is still a research assistant sitting in
the room um
and like you can ask them questions like
hey i think i'm supposed to go up and
wait on this like should i or like hey
how did my form look but they're not
like
actively monitoring and coaching you
through the entire workout um but is
same training program regardless and in
the supervised versus unsupervised
groups uh the the people with more
either supervision or more direct
supervision or kind of more
uh one-on-one hands-on type supervision
even on the same training program those
people tend to
build more strength so you know
regardless of the individualized program
just simply having a coach and someone
that you're accountable to especially if
it's someone you can work with in person
that in and of itself might improve your
results um
and one other thing to note as well is
even though there haven't been all that
many studies in resistance training that
have specifically looked at
individualizing training in the way we
would probably think of it so you know
doing
a big intake questionnaire to try to
tailor every programming variable to
someone's
unique needs and specifications there
are a lot of studies that use
a research paradigm called a within
subject unilateral design where
basically if there are two training
interventions instead of recruiting
subjects and splitting them into two
groups what you do is just recruit one
group of subjects and uh like split
their sides of their body into different
training programs so like you know you
might have one leg doing high intensity
training and the other leg doing high
volume training um and essentially you
look to see
if like within individual um you know
someone's leg responds much better to
one style of programming versus another
or just like one mix of training
variables versus another
and in those studies what you tend to
see is that people who respond well to
training just respond well to training
period and people who don't respond well
to training don't respond well to
training period like the the within
subject correlation between training
responses leg to leg or arm to arm tend
to be quite high where if if you respond
well to one program you'll probably
respond well to the other program as
well
uh there was one particular
within subject unilateral design study
uh that's not coming to mind right now
but the details of it come to mind so it
was looking at manipulating frequency
and volume where if memory serves there
were three conditions there was a twice
per week training three times per week
training and five times per week
training if memory serves um and
essentially the the workout days were
the same regardless so you know it was
just like the three sets of quad work
every time you train um and so you know
the
uh
like training five times per week not
only was frequency higher but total
volume was higher as well because the
per session volume was the same
regardless
and so that was that study also used a
within subject unilateral design and
that's the only paper coming to mind
where there really were
pretty big
within individual differences where some
of the people did respond quite a bit
better to the lower volume and frequency
and some people did respond quite a bit
better to the higher volume and
frequency where like you know if you had
one 2x leg and one 5x leg uh on average
there were larger gains in the 5x legs
than the 2x legs but there were quite a
few individuals where the 2x leg or the
3x leg did have quite a bit larger gains
than the 5x leg so and that suggests to
me like because there have been all
sorts of interventions that have used
um that sort of experimental design and
that's the only study coming to mind
that used that type of intervention
where there were
pretty large within subject differences
between sides of their body which
suggests to me that
more than anything else the factor that
needs to be individualized is just total
training volume and and kind of like the
optimal level of volume
for hypertrophy and strength outcomes
probably does vary quite a bit between
individuals so you know if you're
looking for
you know hey i do want to individualize
my training what variable should i look
at that will likely give me the most
bang for my buck
i think a combination of volume and
frequency probably are the things that
need to be individualized the most um
and other factors you know might make a
small difference but but probably aren't
going to make just a night and day
difference in terms of results
so yeah that wasn't a very
direct and succinct answer to that
question long story short there's
there's not that much research on
specifically on just kind of the
generalized concept of individualizing
resistance training versus putting
everyone on the same program largely
just because that would be a difficult
uh study to design and for it to pass
peer review like you know if if you're
say trying to customize four different
variables you got frequency intensity
volume and exercise selection or
something like that and you have a big
screening questionnaire where
you know you try to to optimize all four
of those variables for a group of 20
people versus another group of 20 people
who are all just put on the same
training program
you would probably wind up with on
average different enough training
interventions in those two groups that
reviewers would look at the paper and be
like well
you know what what are you actually
studying here like maybe the concept of
in individualization but what if the
individualized group just wound up
training with way higher training
volumes like could you really say that
individualization was the driver here
versus just
whatever other training variables wound
up differing between the groups so you
know
i would be interested in reading that
study but i
um i would not
uh i would not want to be the person
designing and conducting that study so
yeah direct research pretty lacking um
but like i said with the with the
vertical jump study there is just kind
of like conceptual evidence in favor of
individualization i do think that a lot
of the benefits from working with a
coach might come from the program itself
but i think a lot of them just come from
working with a coach and there are
inherent benefits to doing that um
and if you're interested in kind of
indirect evidence related to
individualizing training variables and
the sorts of magnitudes of difference
you you could expect from tweaking a
variable here there just keep an eye out
for studies that employ a within subject
unilateral design because that that's
sort of the
research approach
that gives us the best evidence for that
for the types of differences you could
expect within subject from from tweaking
a variable here there
you know i think you said something
really important there um that somebody
ought to do that research as long as
it's not you yep um as you know i cut my
teeth in the laboratory with my hands on
the ultrasound
uh
and the further i get removed from it i
find myself saying that more and more
and more just like
man somebody's got to do this
but absolutely not me yeah it is hard
work man doing research is tough and in
that spirit i do want to uh kind of
clarify and contextualize one of my
previous answers i was talking uh
flippantly about a study about
ashwagandha and i said like ah bench
press went up 46 kilograms maybe that
happened maybe it didn't i said
something like that i want to clarify
that because i i don't want it to sound
like i'm alleging fraud or disparaging
the individuals associated with the
study my concern with that study is uh
the chain the change in bench press even
in the placebo group
is astronomical it wasn't it like 24
kilos in the placebo group or something
like that uh 26 yeah yeah so so the
reason i say you know maybe that
happened maybe it didn't um
is not that i i'm not like alleging
anything nefarious or anything like that
but my concern is that without a really
good standard or a really good
familiarization phase
if you are recruiting from a pool of
individuals who are ready to add that
much to their bench press in eight weeks
there is so much noise and volatility
there are so many big things happening
in your data
fully unrelated to the supplement
intervention that it really undermines
the generalizability of those findings
so i just wanted to clarify that point
uh my big concern there is like if you
have this group of people who they're
just going to touch this weight and grow
no matter what it's really hard to make
inferences about a supplement within
that context and i think that the
i think that the baseline bench press
measurements were very very low and
probably they would have had more
generalizable data if they
just kind of bit the bullet and said
let's do
let's do six weeks or eight weeks of
familiarization and then begin the
supplement trial because when you've got
you know the placebo group almost
doubling their bench press in eight
weeks what could you possibly say about
what the the actual supplements doing
there's so much noise and volatility i
mean
uh yeah there's just a lot of moving
parts when you have
that much lack of familiarity with the
testing outcome that's being measured
yeah so um
yeah it's one of those things when you
when you do the research you realize
like man we gotta give people a break
and be more charitable with you know
with how we interpret studies but anyway
i just wanted to clarify that uh to uh
you know out of respect for the authors
now uh to play us out
uh
stronger by science is the name of the
show i assume that many of our listeners
enjoy science as an extension of that
one of my big regrets in life um that i
may never shake is
i never got to take a good comparative
physiology course where you look at
physiology of different animals because
physiology
in the animal kingdom is insane like
absolutely remarkable so i assume that
our listeners love a good physiology fun
fact and boy do i have a couple
um i was reading about the arctic waters
don't ask why that's not important i was
curious but i came across two animals
that uh
this is just mind-blowing so
the longest living mammal happens to be
up in the northern waters uh floating
around in the ocean there longest living
mammal is the bow head whale lifespan
we've already talked about this so i'm
not going to do the pretend guessing
game
this is a whale and the life span is
estimated up to 200 maybe even 300 years
for a mammal just absolutely insane
that's a long time so i heard that and i
was like man i can't believe these
things are floating around in the water
up there clearly they're the oldest
thing around not even true
in the same the very same waters uh
floating around up there is the
greenland shark this is not a mammal
obviously but the longest living
vertebrate according to these estimates
lifespan of up to 400 to maybe even 500
years uh just absolutely incredible so
i must admit you know right now one of
the things i see on instagram all the
time is
sensationalizing uh ice baths for
literally every outcome you know
take an ice bath if you want to grow
taller if your teeth are itchy
everything in between so uh
maybe i'm wrong dude maybe that's what's
doing it is these uh these sharks and
these whales are floating around up
there in the chilly arctic waters and
they're just living like 500 years
pretty incredible maybe so who's to say
all right are you good for this episode
we're ready to close it out
any parting words for the uh the
listeners
let me think
no i don't think so perfect
that'll generate a lot of curiosity for
what you'll what you'll cook up next
week
all right so that does it for our
special q a episode here we will be back
in exactly one week as always thanks for
joining us